I had him on hangouts oh gosh I guess it
was like three years ago now when he
came out with his book brilliant
blunders well he's recently read another
one called
Galileo and the science deniers and let
me go ahead and bring up Brian so he can
introduce himself and what we're gonna
talk about this week hey Brian how's it
going great Tony can you hear me okay
yeah loud and clear yeah I'm really
looking forward to all these I mean
everybody gets to see how shaggy I'm
getting after all you need to be what I
did you need to do what I did get one of
these coronavirus cuts man oh yeah see
III got the got the trim nice you've got
a excellent in uniformity and ice
atrophy yeah that's exactly yes same
everyone just like the expansion of the
universe it's like it's not growing
I thought relating like my stomach
alright so talk about this week today
we're gonna talk with a mutual about a
mutual friend Mario Livio who's not only
one of the most celebrated you know
astronomers and popularizers of science
but he's also Italian and a scholar and
he has a new book out a wonderful new
book I've read all of his books and his
book called Galilei on the science
deniers is out now and I had the honor
to speak to him last Friday and the
weekend before his book was coming out
and kind of got the inside scoop on a
bunch of topics that I was always
fascinated to learn about you know
you've read my book
losing the Nobel Prize and I have much
to say about Galileo as a hero but also
as a human and I think one of the most
interesting parts of our discussion with
Mario and me was was about Galileo as a
as a father as a ordinary person as a
subject as a religious believer and
someone grappling you know with these
twin kind of desires to understand the
mind of God and also to understand the
works of nature and and how that was
done for the first time and Mario as I
said Italian he's an astronomer and it's
the first biography ever written of
Galileo by an astronomer so it has
insights that are Audion
Our Mutual audience will find unique for
the first time yeah well we have a
couple of clips that we can show for the
interview itself and you just tell me
where you want me to play them but I
want to let people watching this know I
put a link to the full interview and
might be in the description box of my
video and if you have not subscribed to
Ryan's channel yet you need to do that
in the link to that is also in the
description box as well you and you'll
get notified every time he's doing it
when we're done here we're gonna talk
about he has to leave exactly in about
27 minutes so we won't because he's
about to do another interview which will
give you a preview of before he leaves
so alright so what should we just start
with one of the clips or do you want to
give some more because I have some
questions about Galilei own particularly
what's in the book yeah let's let's
let's check out one of the clips but the
thing that I focused on primarily with
Mario was trying to be a little bit
gently as a friend but a little slightly
adversarial and asking the questions you
know that I was hoping would provoke him
into answering for the first time you
know rather than saying you're so
brilliant which I think he is but
instead of just talking about that why
not say challenge him a little bit so
that was kind of my my attempt here to
really get him to open up about you know
how bad is it really I mean this word
denier is it has awful connotations
ranging you know from Holocaust denier
to to other denying denying other sort
of facts in history so I wanted to kind
of talk about that first get a sense of
why he named the book what he did so ya
want we go ahead and roll that and then
you can ask question and then I love
answering questions from the audience
all right so this will be the book the
one that's called Mario book trailer the
but yeah I think they're both called
that but yeah I think we'll see which
one this one is first all right
can you walk the audience through the
choice of the cover design we'll put up
a picture of it and and even the title
of the book let's start there yeah so
well the title you see this is a
biography of Galileo but because Galileo
had to deal with all kinds of science
deniers and because science denialism is
the way I see it a big problem today
then this is what determined the title
Galileo and the science deniers namely
it's a biography of Galileo but with an
eye on science denial today so that's
about the title concerning the image on
the cover so I chose the very first
portrait of Galileo when he was
relatively young probably in his 40s it
was done by an unknown Tuscan painter
but it's the very first portrait known
of him
usually people you know are familiar
with pictures of him by sister months
when he was all even there is one
attributed to Tintoretto and he was sort
of middle aged this one is is is the
earliest so that's that and then there
are these there is this figure of orbits
of planets around the Sun and the way
the cover was chosen is that his picture
is in the middle of that which makes it
look almost as if he is in the bullseye
of a target which kind of describes his
life okay good so couple so I've got I
got several things I want to approach
here one is about Galileo and the story
of Galileo and the other is about
science denialism itself and so and and
I'll ask you Brian these questions so
that you can give me maybe answers in
the context of the interview or what you
know what kind of tease us a little bit
about what's in the interview but I'd
also like your opinions on this first of
all I think and I I have learned and
read quite a bit about the time in which
Galileo lived and during the you know
the very famous trial and all of that
stuff that he went under how accurately
do you think we remember that time
period where Galileo was was promoting
the ideas of Copernicus yeah so the main
controversy that he was teaching was
essentially whether or not the earth was
enter the universe and for reasons you
know Mario is not a biblical scholar I'm
not a biblical scholar but I I can read
ancient Hebrew and I understand some of
the distinction in there what struck me
is that the it's interesting to note I
don't think people have really mentioned
this that there's nowhere in the Hebrew
Old Testament that makes a claim that
the earth is the center of the universe
there's one paragraph that seems to
suggest that Joshua stopped the Sun
which seems to mean that the Sun is
moving around the earth instead of the
other way around
but anyway be that as it may the church
was certainly against the Aristotelian
model of Ptolemaic model that the earth
was going around the Sun because in
their mind things that were close to the
center were of the highest value and you
see this in Dante's Inferno and other
things that that Galilei also lectured
on the controversy was really you know
elevated to this to this stage of lore
and there are books written that
basically paying a very different
portrait from Galileo's and I'll try to
put a link to that in my video at some
point but there you know that it was
sort of overblown and one element of
that that I challenged Mario on in the
interview was uh you know he was allowed
to teach or he was allowed to study the
Copernican universe even by the church
even by the man who later became the
Pope as long as he didn't teach it and
that distinction was crucial because in
the Siderius nuncius that those words
are Latin and that means starry
messenger in Latin but he wasn't allowed
to teach an Italian and he found that
out in 1616 and the dialog oh the
dialogue which really promotes
Copernicanism wasn't published until
1632 so so he had 16 years he wasn't you
know denied any freedoms he wasn't
edited and censored in the way that we
normally think that Mario goes through
this wonderful discussion of the books
between the Siderius nuncius and the
dialogue oh and how this is part of a
canon that Galileo was really intent on
unsettling Copernicus and once and for
all and the ironic thing is that none of
his discoveries really proved that the
earth was going around the Sun they just
merely quote-unquote
he made he's my hero so I'm saying this
again I'm try to be provocative I tried
to take the Pope side in things ironic
for someone who's Jewish by the way and
I keep pointing out that you know I keep
I keep saying I'm the devil's advocate
but I'm really the Pope's advocate you
know just gently because I think
interviews like that are more fun so I
took the Pope side and your listeners
can let me know if I did a good job or
not yeah and I'm glad to hear you say
that because it's there's a lot of my my
wife I learned a lot about this after I
married my wife who is a not only a
Catholic but in a theologian but a
philosopher and she taught me a lot
about this history and about what the
Catholic Church and the role of the
Catholic Church in our scientific
history which is actually quite
extensive and you're absolutely right
and if Mario mentions this in the book
so as he is all that this idea that
Galileo the only that they had you know
the Pope and the Catholic Church had no
problem with what he was doing what they
just didn't want him to do was to try
and interpret it in terms of the Bible
what does this all mean because at the
time the church was under a lot of
pressure because they had the
Reformation going on they were fighting
for their survival they just wanted
Galileo to stop right and just not yeah
you know not proselytize that's right
and he was deeply religious himself I
know so interesting that's right you go
through and you read the book and you
find out Mario is quoting all these
Jesuit astronomers that's right you're
like well if they were really anti
science the way that some people are you
know in some sense
why were they employing astronomers you
know affected that astrologers actual
astronomers who are tracking movements
of things in the heavens for specific
scientific purposes as I always say you
know if you do I never try to convert
people I never try to make a case for
for any type of religious practice or
secularism whatsoever but if you are
religious if you have religious
inclinations I'm sure your wife has
discussed this with you many times
there's no kind of more interesting
angle than to that I basically think all
theologians should be scientists not to
say that they're you know not doing a
good job if they don't but if they
ignore science they're really ignoring
possible dimension that could you know
compliment things that are of interest
to them so I feel like the tension
usually is put as
is being suppressed by religion but I
actually think it's it's because
religious people aren't as interested in
science as they could be or should be
yeah I mean it's been true since the
beginning and I'm talking again about
Catholics because I know that's what I
know the most about that you know that
whenever scientific evidence has come to
light they have not been in denial of it
and and and i think even neil degrasse
tyson said this once where periodically
the catholic church has gone back and
reinterpreted the bible in light of new
evidence they've never done that because
it wasn't it's not their job to do that
and so they never they haven't said well
the bible needs to be now interpreted in
light of this new evidence as the
following thing because they realize
that a lot of this these stories and the
sources of the stories and the purpose
for which these stories were written the
audience for which these stories are for
does not always coincide with the
scientific evidence out there and so
that's right it's it's there really
isn't and I've made this and I'll talk
about this more guys after because of
Bob Bryan's here I want to use Brian but
about my own opinions on this but the
there is not a war in my opinion between
science and religion and there really
never has been but you know that's up to
all I'll talk more about that when I a
little bit later on so ok let well so he
presents in the book a picture of
Galileo his life the way in which he
lived there's been a lot of biographies
on Galileo but it sounds to me like the
interesting part of this book at least
to me is this connection between
Galileo's time and the denial of science
so how does he make that connection yeah
I think those that elements really
interesting and I think the deep
astronomy and into the impossible
audiences will find the astronomical
perspective that Mario brings is a
prominent astronomer too to light no pun
intended that he has a different
dimension into this book just as a
historian you know of middle or you know
Renaissance art will have a different
perspective than a modern artist on say
Michelangelo or Leonardo da Vinci
whatever so so that makes this book very
interesting to people like me but the
history and the kind of obviously the
catchy provocative title that it uses
really set set set
things in motion for me wanting to
really get into it with Mario and so I
asked him questions you know in what
sense was he really punished for his
beliefs in other words if you look at
what happened to him
he was forbidden to do something he not
only did what he was forbidden to do
again I'm taking devil's advocate Pope's
advocate mm-hmm he only did it he taught
it in Italian which was basically
proselytizing a message of that the
church didn't had forbidden him to to
speak but finally he also was you know
kind of so in love with the theory that
he that he really kind of presented
evidence that isn't fitting in other
words he was sort of suffering from
confirmation bias that you and I talked
about quite frequently and it runs the
gamut from you know going to to the
links of being punished by the Vatican
know what happened to him his punishment
I said it's I think Bernie Madoff would
trade trade punished you know prison
cells with Galileo in a heartbeat
because actually part of the interview I
have in my zoom background pictures that
I took in 2015 from Galileo's imprisoned
villa where he spent the last eight
years of his life and Tony I got to tell
you if I ever you know have to be
imprisoned by the NSF or my funding
agencies or whatever that I hope it'll
be there because I already would have
been I suppose because of all the
blunders I've made in my life but um but
this is a sumptuous villa with grape you
know and olive orchard and it was it was
not far for it was about a kilometer you
can see the nun convent where his
daughter one of his daughters Malia
Maria Celeste was was a nun because she
was illegitimate and back then it was
very difficult for women that didn't
have legitimate parents so he was not
only permitted to live in a pretty
sumptuous villa he was living near his
daughter so what kind of you know
oppression and and and suppression was
this now he had to it's true he did have
to bend down his knee in front of the
Pope you know but it wasn't like there
was Twitter and paparazzi and and and
that you know their paintings that
survived and even from that that epoch
even from that from that situation where
he was forced to bow down and
can't that the earth is this goes around
the Sun allegedly Mario debunks this
myth or puts test to the myth
perhaps myth that Galileo actually said
under his breath it still moves even
despite what the Pope is commanding me
to say in other words he muttered under
his breath it said uh the earth still
moves and so Mario has a piece in
Scientific American that I'll link folks
to and the podcast as well that he did
with Steve mirskiy and he talks a little
bit about how he came to challenge this
myth and confront it with facts
throughout history so I think those
kinds of things paint a portrait of
Galileo as a human being as a man not
just not just the you know true truth
seeker at all cost who is punished and
tortured for science that's that's sort
of mythological there's actually a book
called tortured by science or Galileo on
trial one of these and again it's sort
of debunking the myth that he was a
martyr for science he was a great man he
was treated unfairly his message
resounds more than ever but he was you
know he was no saint he was not perfect
because like you and me he was a man
yeah yeah so would would would you say
that the getting back to the concept of
denying science or at least I don't know
that it's fair to even say that there
was a lot of denial of science going on
well me I guess it was sure in in in
Galileo's time do you think there's much
difference between what happens in but
what's happened several hundred years
ago and today with respect to denying
science and why do you think it's so
prevalent now or is it really prevalent
and we've got some kind of bias because
we're scientists I think I think the
latter I think you're absolutely right
you know you see things through this
lens of science and the perspective is
oh yeah it's very harsh I think you know
though he had a book review in nature
which was mostly positive about this
book but it also cited a concern that I
had you know really the only science
that he claims is being denied is global
warming in this book modern science
except I say
an organization and entity that and in
other words there's there is say denial
of evolution say but that's not you know
the the country's policy or enacted upon
some treaty that we withdraw from or
something in the way that global warming
is or climate change so I think the
examples were kind of thin and you know
he wants to guard against the you know
kind of theocracy or autocracy but
really the main message he had was was
about in the book was about climate
change denial ISM and then secondly
there was another you know thing that he
brought up just because of the time in
which the book is being released not
when it was written about kovat 19 and
and how we should listen to scientists
and so we debate that a little bit
because not all the models and not all
the you know the scientists have the
exact same thing to say and I actually
made the point you know not to give
myself too much credit but I did make
the point that like look what Einstein
was he assigns denier I mean he didn't
believe the universe is expanding he
vehemently opposed it he called the
matrice Serie of the primeval atom which
later became called the Big Bang he
called that an atrocious misapplication
of his theory until he was shown
evidence to the contrary now you know
you're a Pope back in the 1600s what do
you what is your job is it to like make
be the final arbiter of scientific truth
I don't I don't think so I think you
know there again I put on my devil's
advocate hat and said well if there was
some asteroid coming to the earth what
would be your role as kind of king or
monarch of the planet would it be to
tell everybody the truth that they're
about to die or would it be a key piece
and that I want people to listen to his
answer and see if it convinces them yeah
the there's a lot of to me science
denialism okay you brought up the idea
of Einstein and you know he didn't like
certain ideas certain certain scientific
theories but he had good reasons for not
liking those things and you know in many
cases this idea of quantum mechanics he
also didn't like but you know he's he
didn't act in bad faith and to me that's
where
a lot of the denialism of today comes
from it's just a willful a willful
ignorance that they don't that there
isn't a good-faith attempt to look at
the facts there's just this flat-out
denialism that's going on in the face of
you know obvious up you know
observations you can debate the the some
of the details like whether the models
are gonna be you know plus or minus
twenty percent or whatever they're going
to be but it's the idea even the basic
methods of science are being denied and
even you know not trusted and that's to
me dangerous right especially today with
not just the corona virus but also you
know just about everything else you know
our our existence is going to be
threatened by this inability to accept
our observations about the world and
this lack of trust that goes on and I
think there's probably good reasons for
people to not trust Authority and not
trust us science but at some point
you've got to have a good faith effort
at looking at the facts around you and
just said of just being destroying your
hands out and say well nothing anybody
says in the scientific world I'm never
gonna listen to and I don't know if it
was like that in Galileo's time but it
sure sure seems that way today yeah I
think so I think there's this mythology
that we cultivate that word is walking
with the P D a--'s and we're infallible
and least in the public mind Oh trust
science and you know I heard it pointed
out that like it took you know took
nuclear physicists working on the
Manhattan Project to develop the bomb
but they didn't go around and say oh you
know Richard Fineman - you'd help
develop the bomb should we drop it I
mean he's very brilliant man but a
politician Harry Truman this made that
decision now you can argue with who's in
politics now and that's why we live in a
democracy I felt to be honest with you I
love Mario but I felt the examples could
have been beefed up a little bit I see
people in the chat asking about UFO
science I agree you can deny it you can
refute different facts that are claimed
about the universe that the universe of
the earth is flat you can refute that
with facts but there's no policy that's
coming down next week
or maybe the week after we'll talk about
saris Cole's his book about UFOs and
this whole culture fueled by billion
dollars billionaires and millionaires
and you know funding the search for UFOs
and and really popularizing it and
that's a little bit more invidious
because it's getting into you know front
page articles in the New York Times
month after month you know this is
happening and and releases without any
contrivance whatsoever there's great
work being done to debunk these videos
that are coming out from fighter pilot
again so you know a pilot a pilot's very
good he or she is a great skill and it's
very hard to master it but you know can
they interpret optical phenomena they
know about illusions they don't know
about Senate signal-to-noise ratios and
beam patterns interference things in the
infrared spectrum angular resolute know
that course not and we don't want them
to I want them to be good pilots similar
I want scientists to be good scientists
not be responsible for making all the
policy decisions in the world I think
one look at my department or you know a
physics department anywhere will tell
you that you know scientists aren't the
best politicians no no they're not even
the best communicators so there's a lot
of but they're good at you know
interpreting nature and that's what we
want them to be good at it and it's the
other people's job like you and I to
discuss and communicate their science
that's right out there so we don't need
them to do that but okay quick wait I
just want to ask you about before we
started I saw a comment I'm sorry I
don't remember who made it I tried to
scroll up and didn't see it
this idea of flat earthers would you
consider them science deniers well so no
yes I think that that you know I would
consider them just ignorant I wouldn't
say that they deny science any more than
you know if you use a map to get around
your city and Florida are here in San
Diego I the world sure looks flat but if
you look at it from that perspective you
know I can put my hand in front of my
face and say well you know nothing is
possible to be seen stereoscopically oh
but you have a better perspective right
so I think it's the lack of
inquisitiveness to actually follow
evidence now if they deny rationality if
you show them Evan
you show them different ways to prove
and it's very simple to do so you can
you can easily prove that now on the
other hand and that's why the church
didn't deny that the earth is spherical
you know roughly spherical although
there's a great quote
you know from Isaac Asimov who says you
know if you believe the earth is is
round you're wrong because it's not
perfectly round but if you believe it's
not a perfect sphere it has some
distortions but if you believe the earth
is flat you're also wrong and you're
much wrong in a much worse fashion here
much more egregiously wrong I think if
you believe something without evidence
or in the face of counter factual
evidence then you can maybe be elevated
to the class of denialism if you believe
stuff like you know the moon landing
didn't happen there's differences
between you know believing and
conspiracies or that UFOs are here and
that colors a little bit more with
political leanings and so forth
so I don't necessarily think that I
actually made a joke yesterday or two
days ago that although the the earth is
not flat the whole universe is known to
be flat that's right that's exactly
right
comfort in that yeah so yeah that's a
good that's a good distinction and I and
I guess for me with when it comes to
thinking about the the Flat Earth right
you know people and the ones that are
denying other parts of science it has to
do it's more of a trust issue it's this
justice sort of a they just something
about authority that they're just not
willing to buy and they feel like
they're being sold ability goods by not
only the scientific community but in
their and their leaders and everything
else these same people will will go out
and and have problems with other parts
of science as well not just whether the
earth is flat or not and they seem to
want but but on the other hand they also
are the ones that I've seen that they're
being honest in their investigation of
the Flat Earth actually try to employ
some pretty good scientific methods are
they're flawed but at least they're
trying to think of it in a way that
proves it to them that the earth is flat
and so I mean one example was in a
during an eclipse you you it they tried
to recreate the shadow going in the
opposite way because it goes the
opposite way from west to east when
during an eclipse and so they were
trying to
make the the disk of the moon smaller
than the earth and they couldn't do it
properly because they were using an
extended light source and so they would
use a flashlight on a tennis ball on it
and of course the the [ __ ] gets really
big and when you shine it on a wall had
they used a point source they would have
seen you know that this would have been
a little bit better it would have
actually gone dead the shadows would
have worked right so I don't know
I mean they try to do it but if you're
doing an earnest look again Galileo
didn't prove that the earth goes around
the Sun in fact I wasn't proven know
until the 17 or 1800s when we could do
measurements of what's called stellar
aberrations so if you really want to
annoy a scientist I was talking to a PhD
yesterday I said proved to me that the
Sun is the center of the solar system
and he ever think for a long time before
he could actually come up with some
ideas to prove it without using a rocket
ship India just proved it to me here on
earth it's pretty hard to do
yes Copernicus was wrong when he died
Galileo was wrong when he died Newton
was wrong when he died these are right
but you know they still contributed a
lot toward science and so far Einstein's
been right about everything but you know
who knows where we'll go with this okay
we're almost out of time what's next
week what do you let's talk about your
next interview so people can get a test
a taste of what your body I'm gonna be
interviewing in my controversial
cosmology some series seminar and these
episodes that I'm calling pandemic
podcasts I'm gonna be recording with
Eric Weinstein of Steel Capital
geometric unity is his new model of the
universe I want to talk to him about
that one it'll be the first time he's
talking to a physicist an actual living
breathing physicist so instead of Joe
Rogan who's I don't believe a physicist
who nobody plays one on TV that's right
yeah he might be a theoretical I'm just
a humble experimentalist and then but
maybe next week we'll talk about yes era
skulls his book called they are already
here and yesterday I recorded an episode
that's coming out of my channel on
Sunday for Mother's Day with Sascha
Segan whose girls Sagan and Andrew Ian's
daughter and I want to talk about that
we could talk about that next week we
could talk about this era skulls book
we have a lot of really good interviews
coming up this is in the arthur c clarke
centers into the impossible podcast and
on my youtube channel you can subscribe
to both please because actually we do
different things the video ones we give
away we don't give away anything and the
audio ones we give away a copy of the
book at least once our local book store
opens up here we will give away a copy
of the book and and then hopefully
people will enter to win that and then
the video on the YouTube channel I give
away well I don't give away we we do
interviews and we add in graphics links
show notes exercises for the reader so I
think it's it's kind of fun I'm having a
lot of fun in this lockdown period dude
yeah you're making some great content
and so I would encourage everybody to
get on your channel and subscribe to
these podcasts because these are great
people to be discussing all of this with
and and recently you've done we talked
about this briefly Freeman Dyson who has
recently passed away is now also
somebody you were able to talk to so a
lot of great people so definitely guys
alright so next week we'll we'll be back
next time on the 21st I'll just warn
everybody I think I've got a double a s
hangout planned in two weeks but next
week we'll be here so we'll be back with
Brian and we'll talk about some more
cool stuff so thanks Brian I know you
got to go so just go ahead and and hang
out thanks Donnie I'll hang up now but
you have a great day and yeah so I will
I'll hang around for a little bit longer
and talk to you guys
hey face roll yeah he's he's a teacher
at UCSD as a professor there let's see
so let me look at some of you I've been
I was so because he had a hard cutoff he
had to get to I didn't read a lot of
your chat so let me do that now
hey Andrew it's good to see you again
Varun Vega on Twitch it's good to see
you as well and better and better it
looks like you're everywhere man you're
both on twitch and youtube by the way I
am streaming on all the things except
for Instagram I'm not streaming on that
but so I'm everywhere always so let's
see here Andrew planet science denial is
an artifact xual expression of our
species
of adaptations for social order based on
physical aggression aided and embedded
by guests lighting I love it bad that's
also UFO science is denied no actually
the people there are there are actual
unidentified flying objects what so
people do study what these things are
but what the connection between
something that's unidentified in the air
and a an alien that that connection is
is probably not science
Galileo's dream is a good book by Kim
Stanley Robinson's a good one Simon I
like that yes that's right John he could
still entertain guests and even go out
into his garden where he could watch
apples falling and totally failed to get
the hint I love it that's great I do
believe in God but not in a specific one
just someone who created okay that's
good and artifice is commenting they're
the ones responsible for building
schools back in the colonial is
colonialism error I think you must be
talking about Catholics and also I
wanted to thank cons milling for the
super chat Thank You Man yes it will go
towards my new camera this I'm using an
old logitech camera right now as you can
no doubt tell it's not the best quality
but it is getting the job done so yeah
so thank you Hans I appreciate the I
appreciate the support
humans are egotistical and narcissistic
says Varun Vega and I certainly are
self-centered that's for sure
it's hard to I like to think they're
more empathic than they are but I don't
know let's see the earth is flat
evolution is only a theory kovat is just
a flu that's for market to PES and you
were almost banned dude first day of
that okay so I think that's the Simon's
going I'm trying to say this with them
is the most respect is possible but I
really appreciate dr. Keating's
transformation and communication style
from his SETI Institute lecture days
good I guess you weren't happy with
those days but you know as he as he will
point out you know he's we're all
evolving we're all growing a little bit
and certainly I've made a lot of
blunders and streaming online or talking
and giving talks so Tony switched
Thursday's that's right so yes it's been
you know thing I enjoyed talking with
him and he gets access to a lot of
really great people and he's promised
that he's gonna connect me with some of
them so I wouldn't mind talking to Eric
for a while and I might give a lot Mario
back I have no problem with really just
like bearing down on people and trying
to get him to say you know stuff that
they might not ordinarily say but um let
me just point out I want to point out
something to you guys this is you know
when talking about Galileo let me see if
I can get this switched over what is
that that and we're gonna push some
buttons here for just a minute yeah here
we are
okay here is a picture a very famous
picture that was that was painted
depicting the Inquisition of Galileo and
here I hope you can see yes good my my
cursor is here here's old you know
there's a lot of symbolism here you have
Galileo standing defiantly here off to
the right with a with a it's almost a
halo around him around his head the
arbiter of science and then standing
here is a you know with their backs
literally against the wall rd is the
Catholic Church you know trying to argue
and fight with him about his beliefs and
ideas but one of the you know this to me
is one of the first examples of the myth
of Galileo being this big you know
arbiter of you know de fire of the
church in the sense that he was trying
to you know just say things that that
put the church at on the defensive and
he was doing those things but this was
painted if I scroll down here 1857
this is several hundred years after the
actual events took place and so the
there's the and this is sort of one of
the examples of this what I think is
another myth of this war of so-called
war between science and religion early
on the church the Catholic Church had
been very involved in our scientific
progress in fact they were the only ones
in the Western world at least
progressing things early as I think it
was beed the venerable was like in the
was I can 400 I'm getting my dates very
good but very close to 400 AD or so not
too long after Constantine switched to
Catholicism and he was one of the first
to rien to to write theories about how
the earth being round picking up on the
Greeks again and their and their work
and then we've got there's and all the
way up through Newton's time where Isaac
Newton was an extremely religious source
a religious person in fact he wrote more
scienter religious papers than he did
scientific papers and so he was you know
he always looked at himself as a
religious person first and foremost so
there is room for both is the point I'm
trying to make
I am personally an atheist but you know
I I respect the history and I want to
look at it with honesty of what has
happened in the past with with religion
so I think that we too often take these
myths and we distort them in ways that
are unhealthy and I think they also
breed a lot of the mistrust that we see
in the science denialism of today if
people would just and and scientists
don't help their case any they that we
have very prominent scientists out there
neil degrasse tyson's done a bill nice
done it although he's not a scientist
he's a communicator and we and and
Richard Dawkins at all doing some rat
doing some rather intense damage to the
scientific cause
I just just being belligerent towards
people of faith and so I don't think it
helps and I don't and I end and I don't
think that that is a it's an honest
approach I think it's just a way of
getting science trying to show up
science down people's throats in ways
that are inappropriate and so I feel I
feel very strongly about this idea that
you know there is not a war between
science and religion
at least there hasn't been in the past
and so with all of this scientists a
scientism that's been attacking religion
and religion taya fights back with its
with its trying to be more scientific
using scientific arguments in there to
justify their faith I think that's also
a mistake right we have you know the
creationism is a prime example of that
where we have examples of museums where
you can go to and and see you know this
these sort of dubious depictions of
human beings alongside dinosaurs and
this idea that the earth really is only
six thousand years old
the literalism of the Bible is I think a
dishonest portrayal of what the faith is
trying to communicate and so it's been
distorted on both sides but it's also I
think science doesn't have any real
business making these comments about
things that aren't scientific and that's
the kinds of thing that the scientistic
people of today are doing I think and I
think it's a dissident I think it's a
disservice so I don't know what do you
guys think it's I know that I know that
there are you know a lot of high
emotions on this topic I am I am NOT a
militant atheist I think and I think
people that are really wreak a lot of
havoc in the world by just being so
militant about everything and then
trying to insert themselves in search
science in places where it doesn't
belong
so and these ideas were you know of
Galileo being you know at odds with the
church I think we've all sort of learned
now it wasn't quite like that his
prisons were his did you know he was he
was a little bit belligerent he was also
part of the problem so he was you know
he was he's also very plagiaristic he
took a lot of people's ideas and made
them as if they were his own he would he
would teach them as if they were his own
so he was a it was part of the problem
in that sense as well and things could
have gone a lot differently for Galileo
had he may be shown a little more
respect for what he you know what he was
trying to teach at the time and if he
had just you know the Pope as we've
recently learned he just said look will
you support what you're doing the work
is valid just stop interpreting it in
terms of the Bible just stop doing that
and and that's the job of the church the
Bible is the part is the job of the
church and let us let us handle that you
handle the science and we'll be fine
unfortunately didn't work out that way
so so there is no proof for good if
there is good he wants you to believe
not no I think you mean God but I'm a
factual list but I'm not an atheist as
that's sort of a hot face a fate ism and
Chris Chris goes I'm sorry Tony I
disagree the likes of Christopher
Hitchens Dawkins and Krauss are around
90% of the rest of world is just seen as
common sense it's only America that
makes that takes offense well okay so if
I've read all of Richard Dawkins books
and and a couple of Christopher Hitchens
books and while I can't cite examples
I'll top my head because I don't have
that kind of memory anymore I can tell
you that they are they are making claims
in their books that have to do with you
know science disproving God or you know
this you know that the view of science
is the only right view that there is and
it is the only view of the universe that
will ever make sense and that is where
they do humanity and knowledge in
general a great disservice because
not true there are other forms of
knowledge that can be gained without
side of the realm of science and so what
they what they tend to do is get away
from the boundary of where science works
what is science science is our way of
understanding the mechanics and the
workings of nature and if it stays in
that realm it does a very very good job
and the technology that flies out of
doing that science is extremely
successful so there's no there's no
question of the success of science in in
the quality of our lives and in the
advancement of our technology but an
argument can be made that the scientific
progress that we have enjoyed over these
past five hundreds or some odd years
however long it is has come at the
expense of some other levels of
knowledge that we that we are kind of
losing touch with so to give an example
why are you know some very fundamental
questions that are important to each and
every one of us are outside of the realm
of science an example would be why do I
love my wife these are these are very
basic and put highly important questions
well I don't have a scientific answer I
could go down to the biological hormonal
level and explained why by hormones are
reacting the way they are and why I why
am I my brain synapses and how they are
operating to produce this thing called
love but it doesn't tell me what love is
it falls far short of that so I am
gaining other knowledge about the world
and experience about the world in ways
that that are outside of the world of
science another example would be you
know morality are their absolute more or
is there an absolute right and wrong to
the universe or is everything relative
these are things that science isn't
going to be able to put an experiment on
and give you an answer for these things
and yet they are incredibly important
sources of information why we do what we
do you know why is murder wrong or is it
really wrong right it affects our lives
and it is a very important part of who
we are and yet science is not a part of
it okay
sure we can give profiles of murderers
and serial killers and we can say oh you
know the reason this person is doing it
is because he's got some kind of
narcissistic personality disorder and he
doesn't have any empathy biologically
and so he murders people but is that
really the whole answer and so it's I
think we lose sight of the other areas
in life where science really doesn't
have a lot to say but and can't really
contribute and yet these people like
Hitchens and and whom whom I respect
okay I mean these are people I've read I
know I buy their books and I and I
listen to their arguments
I just think their arguments are
unconvincing because they are being
first of all belligerent and to the
point of just making themselves sound
famous or be famous and to be and to be
somewhat argumentative about the topic
which is fine that's okay they just want
their personality out there which is you
know part of what makes people famous
but they're also I think disingenuous in
this in this insertion of science and
places that it really you know Richard
Dawkins has tried I think in it
certainly in the day I think it was in
The Selfish Gene where he tried to
invoke scientific reasons for why you
know we behave the way we do you know
with with respect to morality but I
found them very unconvincing so I would
recommend a book to you that I found
very good it was called monopolizing
knowledge and it's written by a
physicist at MIT and who's a devout
Catholic and his name is Ian Hutchison
and that book more than any other I've
read gives the arguments about why
scientism does harm and and people like
Richard Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens
and Sam Harris these are all scientistic
people they aren't scientists they are
they believe in scientism which is this
belief that
thing in the universe can be framed in
the world of science and in the in the
words of science and with and it can be
discovered but the methods of science
and and so I would encourage you to read
that book if you if you go to my Amazon
page I have a link to it on there but
you'll find it it's it's available on
Kindle and on Amazon and all that kind
of stuff and it's called monopolizing
knowledge and it's you know written by
you know a playa a particle physicist or
maybe it's a plasma physicist I forget
anyway at MIT he's not just some he's
working practicing scientist and so he
does a good job I think of framing the
problem a lot better and I just did so
there are no absolutes is an absolute
statement that contradicts itself right
so yes and and you know there there's
lots of arguments like that that end up
just being self contradictory and I
think a lot of the atheists that we see
out there are being self contradictory
and they're trying to just own the
religious people that's the goal right
let's own them because that's what we do
now we own the other side whatever the
other side is we just want to own it and
that is such a counterproductive way to
behave that you know what do you
possibly expect to gain from owning the
flat-earthers
are you ever gonna win that argument
first of all it's a hopeless hopeless
cause they don't they aren't gonna be
convinced because they're not believing
in a flat earth for reasons that have
anything to do with rationality they are
believing in a flat earth this is my
theory are that because they are part of
a community of people of which they are
a valued member and we all want to be a
part of a valuable community science or
the mainstream whatever has rejected
them in whatever way and they've and
they found a home among people who
believe these weird things but they are
accepted and they are trusted and they
are welcomed in that's why they're flat
earthers they're not flat earthers
because they really
this they want they don't they think
that the earth is actually flat they do
but that's that's not the real reason
why they're there because if you somehow
could convince them rationally with a
beautiful proof that the earth is in
fact round of course we have all this
proof to give them and they get you know
you're right you're right the earth is
round I have been wrong what is the
consequence of that admission they are
going to be ostracized from a community
that they already feel a very important
part of they will be ostracized from
their friends and suddenly their life
has changed they've got a lot invested
in this idea that the earth is flat and
the same you know the same is true for a
lot of you know I had the example in it
and it went away
I don't want to say cult but a lot of
people who were in these cults they are
in them because of the acceptance level
and they aren't lit they aren't
interested in a rational argument for
why why things are the way they are
that's not you're not going to convince
them ever so why do it
you know why get in the people's face
and just be belligerent are you doing
yourself or your cause any good has
anything ever changed from all the books
that Richard Dawkins has written or that
Christopher Hitchens has done has there
been any real change has he changed any
minds and what's the point of doing it
other than riling up your own side and
yeah go ahead rile up you rile up your
side get get really mad at all the
religious people and just own the hell
out of them and then what what are you
gonna do with all that anger right have
you done any real made any real progress
here so if I I don't get it I mean I I
understand why people are angry and
upset at people who won't believe in
certain parts of science I get that it's
annoying it's highly aggravating and I
would argue it's also dangerous
especially when you've got things like a
pandemic to deal with it's if we do
develop a vaccine do you honestly think
there was some somebody had told me I
think it was a survey had been done
where 30% of Americans won't take it if
a vaccine that for the Cova 19
[Music]
coronavirus is developed 30% of
Americans won't take it because they
don't trust anything scientists say and
why don't they trust it it's because of
these books God is not great The Selfish
Gene The God Delusion
you know the end of faith these are all
books that preach to a choir that goes
then out and causes a lot of damage and
so that's my that's my thinking on it
and I know that I just pissed off 90% of
you but I like I said I am an atheist I
do not believe I cannot get to the point
where I believe in a God but I can
certainly respect the thinking and the
faith that goes into it I can't make
that leap of faith that that religious
people can make but I can respect it and
I can try and understand it better than
I do
morality right and wrong imagination
creativity all of these things are
non-scientific and we should value them
every bit as much as we value the
scientific method such as it is or isn't
really a method it's just a bunch of
people trying to pretend there's a
method but it's it's a very flawed
endeavor full of human foibles that end
it also science itself depends on very
unscientific things you've heard me say
this before science you invent you you
come out with a new scientific idea that
is actually quite plausible and the
first thing you're going to be met with
is a bunch of her rump first telling you
how full of [ __ ] you are and that's that
you can't possibly be right and I'd be
like are you wrong it's all crap I mean
oh you only have to look at professor
Higgs to realize you know that you know
what it's like to be ridiculed for most
of your scientific life only then later
to be found out to be to be right so you
know it's based on very human problems
and we depend on things like creativity
do you honestly can you fully appreciate
Einstein went through when he made the
leap that wait a minute the speed of
light is fixed and it's time that is
relative to everything that and relative
to emotion
what kind of creativity would have to
make that leave what what do you have in
here that lets you make that leap it and
science doesn't progress without that
kind of quality without an imagination
without the creativity to take what
you've learned to take the scientific
method and use human creativity to make
something to make it grow so science
depends on things that are not
scientific
and so I'm I just don't buy it I don't
buy this crap that science is all there
is it's just too narrow and to be
belligerent about it
because it's easy to say well science is
so great because we've done all these
things right and if you don't believe it
you're just a [ __ ]
is the road wrong approach to take and
it never it's never ever it made the
situation better no one's been called
stupid or a [ __ ] and then gone back
home you know what I like what Richard
Dawkins said he's actually right you
know what they're saying is they hate
the [ __ ] and he won it they you
know he's he's an [ __ ] that's what
they're saying
so what good has he done he's made you
feel better because you like him and you
follow him and you'll read everything he
does you're like you're richer men own
to own the religious people I think
that's a wrong way to go about it okay
so who I've got the vapors now you guys
giving me the vapors this is a topic
I've thought a lot about will science
prove the probability of God no it won't
it won't it is not a scientific question
the the but the definition of God is
that it is outside of nature and if it's
outside of nature science has nothing to
say and and if you'll think about
science is getting scarily
non-scientific these days with this idea
of the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics or these bubble
universe
or these multiverses you know all of
this stuff is getting scarily
non-scientific because there's no way to
prove any of this stuff
we're just saying things because the
math works out so are we all Plato do we
think that mathematics is reality
because if so then all of these things
are true but you know art or do we want
to see an experiment that is devised
that can be shown with observations that
every decision we make branches off into
another universe that to me would be
science but to say that that's what
happened or it seems like a good idea
which is what Sean Carroll says then
that to me it's not very scientific it's
not a scientific statement so be careful
just be careful so anyway science is
part of philosophy
Hans dude I I really think I'm havin
looked at the viewership but I'll bet P
I bet it's plummeted it's probably just
going way down oh there's 56 of you here
well you stuck around I will stop
ranting I want to read I want to give
more concrete examples of the books I've
read and why I think they're misleading
or the or at least dishonest and I think
you know look I get it Christopher
Hitchens was a very smart is it was a
very smart man and all of these guys are
they have good points and I read some of
their points resonate with me I just
feel like it's it's coming from a place
of all-or-nothing
right science is all there is and if you
think of anything else as being true
then you're an idiot and that's
certainly the way Richard Dawkins
approaches the subject you know you're
just a [ __ ]
and you know I like Bill Maher I watched
the Bill Maher show or you say used to
when I had HBO I can't afford it anymore
but when I was watching Bill Maher every
week and went you know he occasionally
have Richard Dawkins on and he the last
interview they had with with him and he
they were talking about religion of
course we all know what Bill Maher
thinks of religion I actually came away
a little bit angry and I actually agreed
with 90% of what they said but it was
the way they said it that actually made
me angry I just like why are you guys
doing this
I was like it's like they just want to
be like Donald Trump only on the left I
just want to make people react they just
want to say things that make you mad or
that make other people matter that make
themselves feel good or they're their
fanboys to feel good and it just makes
the situation so much worse we're
already so tribal we're already so
insular in our thinking that if you're
outside of our little group then you
just suck and you know there's no
intermingling anymore there's no you
know like for example I don't feel like
I have a place you know I don't feel
like I have a real proper community
where I can be a lover of science and
appreciate the wonder of the universe
through the eyes of science and also
really value the ideas of non-scientific
concepts and those in religion I am NOT
gonna sit here and be a a defender of
Catholics they have a lot to answer for
right that church has got a lot of
problems I'm not gonna sit here and say
they are without guilt ins they're in so
many ways in fact it's gotten so bad
that my wife who is a devout Catholic
has actually left the church in terms of
going to Mass because of this priest
scandal thing she can't reconcile the
church leadership as the church as it is
today with what the church has always
taught and what she believes in the
church doctrine so she's actually kind
of left the church a little bit in the
sense that she still believes in what
the Catholics believe in but she she's
lost faith in the church itself and so
I'm not gonna defend what they've done
they've got a history that we all know
about and of course anybody who tries to
is also being disingenuous but they also
have a lot of contributions the first
person that was there was a friar and I
forgot his name now because I'm old who
first came up with the idea before I
think fred hoyle did of an expanding
universe not fred hoyle he called it the
Big Bang but before I think it was in
the early 20th century the late 19th
century
this fryer was one of the first to come
up with society of the big bang and of
course we all know Newton was was a big
contributor and there have been there
have been you know fryers and priests
and monks all throughout the history who
have contributed scientific knowledge
very valuable scientific knowledge for
Humanity so they've got they've got
we've got to acknowledge that right we
just can't ignore it and we got to be
careful of our myths like the Galileo
myth and and other things about how that
whole thing transpired maybe there's a
little bit more to the story right so
okay oh wow it's okay it's time to go um
I don't know yes thank you it was made
Lemaitre am I saying it right yes thank
you sir
sir tall Paul yes that's who it was
that's the one and Simon you did it also
so yes thank you so there we go thank
you and galaxia you said it also before
I did so you guys yeah you guys know
more about this crap than I do so good
for you guys I'm just in you're rambling
and on hans milling it's all about
survival in the old days belonging to a
group secured to survival that's why
people worship famous people like Elon
Musk because nobody wants to be in a bad
standing with the king it's true I mean
there wasn't there's definite survival
advantages to being in a group and human
beings I mean anybody who's in America I
don't know about you guys in Europe I
don't haven't heard about any of these
protests but I certainly have heard
about him here that people are
protesting being under lockdown they
would rather they would rather be out
and about and risk the virus than risk
all the rest of us for getting the virus
then they would rather stay at home
because staying at home and being
separated is very hard for human beings
to do so we have these protests where
people just want to leave and they want
to do what they want to do and take
their own chances and and and the myth
there is that they're only affecting
themselves right the myth there is that
well I don't care if I get it if it's my
time it's my time well maybe not so much
I don't personally want to get it either
and now you're endangering me because
what if I you know I accidentally catch
it from you right
I mean did
10 are you passing judgment on whether I
can get it or not get it so there's
there's this selfishness there that is a
little bit alarming but you know we've
got these protests they don't want to
they don't want to be told what to do
and they don't want to be told to be
locked down and so there is a protest
here where people are just doing what
they want to do anyway and it's only
going to get worse and so it is you know
there is this sort of herd mentality
where we don't want to be cooped up we
don't want to be by ourselves being in a
group it's very very very very important
to human being so you're right Hans
that's a good point
okay so I mean we were in Vegas Ed
Banger says there's an analogy of
science when people try to force a
religion onto some group of people like
Europe and Africa there is science on
religion let them believe in what they
want to believe yes well I mean that's
certainly true and Neil you is Tony what
do you think we lost when they burned
the ancient Library of Alexandria oh my
god who can calculate that what a lock
all of this knowledge had been stored in
a library that we don't even know what
was all the cumulated knowledge from the
Egyptians and the times then that and
the centuries and the millenia before
had been gathered in one spot and burned
to the ground I think it was in
Cleopatra's time but I don't know for
sure it would have been right it close
to the the time of the new millennium
the you know coin from BC to BCE into
the Common Era and I don't I think it
was around that switching period I don't
think Christ was alive then I might have
been before him or just after him I
can't remember but yeah I mean the the
amount of knowledge that would have been
lost in Alexandria is incalculable you
know it would be probably equivalent to
the entire Internet being wiped out
that's basically all of our knowledge is
stored on the internet now and so if it
had somehow all been erased it would be
an equivalent thing to that so yeah it
was it was quite a loss and and who
knows how far that set us back right we
had we had gained this knowledge and it
wasn't until say three or four hundred
years later when people started to apply
some of these principles to regain
that knowledge that we had religion
doesn't destroy everything - but if it
doesn't I mean that's just a wrong
you're just wrong
when you say that it's it's that's just
not a true statement so let's see from
the topic astronomy though you should
make a separate channel for philosophy
perhaps Hans I did the top of this this
sort of brought up this brought up the
out this discussion with Galileo and
science denialism and lack of trust in
science and then this whenever someone
brings up the scientistic people the
scientism in the world I get a little
bit angry because I'm upset about how
that is is ruining things and I do
believe it is it's wrong because
religion doesn't ruin everything how can
any one thing raloo ruin everything
what exactly does that even mean tulip
it
I mean science rules that ruins
everything it doesn't I mean I'm still
here my room is still here my my
property everything is - what is it
ruined and what does it even mean to say
it ruins stuff you know what is it
taking away from your quality of life
personally what is it taking away from
all of our quality of life collectively
I mean it doesn't ruin everything
science doesn't make everything great
that's also a wrong statement okay so
don't what does that even mean
that it ruins everything it's wrong I'm
sorry dude gyah d'Arnaud Bruno he
proposed that the stars were distant Sun
surrounded by their own planets and he
raised the possibility that these
planets might foster life of their own
yes I prize human liberty and freedom
but I'm staying on lockdown just saying
yeah you know I'm just I don't want to
get it and if I'm gonna be around other
people I'm probably gonna get it so you
know it's on me I guess you know I'm not
gonna suddenly decide all
well I don't care if I get it now I'm
gonna go out and just endanger others I
actually have a higher moral code than
that
what I do affects other people and I
actually realize that so I'm gonna act
accordingly you know I realize that well
gosh I may not be I may be willing to
take the risk of getting this virus but
others may not be and perhaps just maybe
I should think about them a little bit I
mean this this this this level of
morality that we all have is it's
varying depending on who you are many
people are of the opinion that it's
totally fine this this pandemic you know
what it's a pandemic you're gonna have a
certain amount of collateral damage deal
with it
and I'm not gonna even bother to
minimize it or should I maybe work at
minimizing it and do my part to perhaps
minimize the number of deaths that occur
well that is a very personal question
that you must answer yourself and many
of us are choosing to answer it in the
way of it's a risk I think we should all
take and even though I affect my actions
affect you I'm going to do it anyway
that's just the way human beings are so
we have to accept that I have to plan
accordingly I have to know that if I do
go out which I haven't really I haven't
left my property more than a handful of
times in the past few months for this
very reason and sadly you know poor
Charlotte she goes out and does all the
shopping and does all the this stuff for
us because she doesn't I'm older than
her and she doesn't want me to be a risk
for it so you know we make these
sacrifices so it's all it's all
something you have to ask yourself you
know what yes your take you're willing
to accept the risk of catching the
coronavirus but you're not the only one
in the world and so do you McNall it's
at or do you just behave as if you're
the only one in the world you know and
and and surprisingly a lot of the people
who were behaving this way would
consider themselves to be religious
people so in you know or is it are they
acting this way because of their
religion I would argue now their
religion would probably tell them not to
and to be more conscious of those who
are less fortunate than them and to
perhaps protect those or who are the
weakest among us and yet there are other
factors at work here right there's
political factors economic factors all
these other things that
cause that person who would otherwise
might think of others who are more at
risk than themselves
to go out and endanger them because
their own personal liability is at stake
or their own you know their own food
their own survival may be perceived to
be threatened and it may be it actually
is threatened and so they would act
accordingly on that way there's lots of
reasons why people would do it and it's
my job to understand that that is out
there and act according to my own set of
constraints you know and what made my
own risk tolerance and so I probably
said too much anyway if you've unsub to
the channel I understand I I do have I
don't usually talk like this on the
channel so I probably have made a
mistake so I will stop and any thoughts
on the coming crew Dragon launch yes
Chris let's switch let's switch gears
it's a shame Bowen cut-set Peck yes it's
very true Bowlings are in trouble as a
company I'm going to talk about this
more on tomorrow on my on my weekly
space roundup which I do live on YouTube
and on twitch on Gibson pick channel and
I think it's great I'm very excited
about it I think that it'll be wonderful
you know to get back into the space
business of launching people again and
so I'm really excited about this I may
try so I guess May 26 is the launch date
maybe it's the 27th anyway I'm gonna
actually try and go I think Kennedy the
Kennedy Space Center I the Visitor
Complex
I think opened this week and I'm talking
about social distancing and weather you
know it's a good idea to go I won't go
to the Kennedy Space Center but I say
that because you know that if Kennedy is
open then they'll probably have launch
viewing opportunities to see the launch
I will still won't go there but I do
have a boat and I would take my boat to
Mosquito Lagoon which is just outside of
the launch complex and watch it from
there so I'm considering doing that to
do that though I've got to get my
trailer my boat trailer more work so I
hope to see the launch but I don't know
if I'm going to make it
I'll definitely watch it online as well
I think this is a great time I think I
think SpaceX as a company is doing all
most of the right things and you know
I'm gonna comment on Elon Musk but the
company of SpaceX is actually quite
exciting and bigger rating Boeing not so
much my quite sure if they're even gonna
survive the way things are going for
them so anyway it's a 27th okay thanks
Islands so yeah I'm good I'm gonna
definitely I'm dipping it well okay tuba
pips oh yeah it I don't I don't see okay
I'll give you that it has it hasn't I'm
just gonna take issue with one word you
say that religion has always impeded
science and I'm going to just say you
need to give her that word always it has
impeded science it has slowed things
down made things difficult at times but
it has also progressed science it has
been responsible for adding scientific
knowledge to the world so please
acknowledge that - it hasn't always done
it and so these are these words you're
using always and everything you know we
need to get away from that you know it's
not true
it is yes it has impeded some things it
has made things more difficult it has
been an obstacle at times and it has
ruined some things in the world for sure
anybody who is followed this pre scandal
can say that is probably a very ruinous
thing to have been doing at his behavior
that is no one can justify certainly the
Inquisition's and all of his stuff that
we know from from history that is that
has happened none of this can be
justified morally so but always and
everything let's just maybe not do that
okay so let's see all right so there's a
SETI event happening in 20 minutes I'm
gonna get off thank you Andrew planet
for letting people know okay so I think
I will stop now it is already 15 minutes
past my time
sure okay well everyone I want to thank
you all so much for watching and as
always
Oh Brian by the way you probably got all
of this is streaming on your channel you
might want to edit out the last 30
minutes of what I just did for your own
channel so because ice is also streaming
on is all right okay guys I'll be back
tomorrow night for the weekly space
roundup a to put 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
also on twitch dot-com slide or
twitch.tv slash Gibson pics I'll be on
the clear skies network as well tomorrow
night with the weekly space roundup so
join me there and I'll talk more about
the SpaceX flight and other things so on
behalf of Bryan Keating thank you all so
much for watching and as always keep
looking up
you